- Good afternoon,
everybody, and welcome back.
So let me introduce our
distinguished keynote speaker.
Jhumpa Lahiri is a professor
of creative writing
at the Lewis Center for the
Arts at Princeton University.
She received a
Pulitzer Prize in 2000
for her debut story collection,
Interpreter of Maladies.
Her followup novel,
The Namesake, in 2003
was adapted for
the screen in 2007.
Her book of short stories,
Unaccustomed Earth--
which was being read by the
woman next to me on the plane
on a return trip from Newark
Airport, which was just
about the only part of that
trip that was interesting to me.
Nothing against Newark.
That received the 2008 Frank
O'Connor International Short
Story Award.
Finally, her book The
Lowland, Random House 2013,
also won the 2015 DSC Prize
for South Asian Literature.
After reading her
keynote, Jhumpa
will be accompanied
in conversation
by Celeste Ng, who is the
internationally best selling
author of the novels
Everything I Never Told You,
and Little Fires Everywhere.
She is a Harvard
graduate and also has
received her MFA from the
University of Michigan.
And she has the coolest
Twitter handle ever.
Jhumpa.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, no, no.
They have to guess.
It's pronounced Ng.
But I should have
let you do that.
I'm so sorry.
Jhumpa Lahiri.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I am honored to be here.
And I want to thank everyone
at Radcliffe for inviting me.
I feel like I've been
in this room before.
Is that possible?
I think I might have been here
when The Namesake came out.
And I believe I read here.
Anyway, I feel very comfortable.
That's a good thing.
I'm looking forward to my
conversation with Celeste.
And as a point of
departure, I'd like
to read a short story that was
published a couple of months
ago in The New Yorker magazine.
It's called "The Boundary."
This is a story I
wrote originally
in Italian three years ago
when I was living in Rome.
And it was published in
Italian, in the Italian version
of Granta magazine, which,
sadly, is no longer in print.
Last fall in Princeton, I
decided to translate it myself
into English.
And this is the result. The
title of the story in Italian
is [ITALIAN],, which is the
word for a boundary, a border.
And so I chose "The Boundary"
as the English title.
Every Saturday a new
family comes to stay.
Some arrive early in
the morning from afar,
ready to begin their vacation.
Others don't turn up until
sunset in bad moods, maybe
having lost their way.
It's easy to get
lost in these hills.
The roads are poorly signposted.
Today, after they introduce
themselves, I show them around.
My mother used to
do the welcoming,
but she's spending the summers
in a nearby town helping out
an elderly gentleman
who's also on vacation.
So I have to do it.
As usual, there are four
of them, mother, father,
two daughters.
They follow me, their eyes wide,
happy to stretch their legs.
We stop for a moment on the
shaded patio that looks out
over the lawn under a thatched
roof that filters the light.
There are two armchairs and a
sofa covered with white fabric,
lounge chairs for sunbathing,
and a wooden table big enough
for 10 people.
I open the sliding glass
door and show them inside.
The cozy living room with two
comfortable sofas in front
of the fireplace, the
well-stocked kitchen,
two bedrooms.
While the father
unloads the car,
and the girls who are
probably around seven and nine
disappear into their room,
shutting the door behind them,
I tell the mother where to
find extra towels and woolen
blankets in case it
gets cold at night.
I show her where the
mouse poison is hidden.
Kill the flies before
going to bed, I suggest.
Otherwise they start buzzing
at dawn and become a nuisance.
I explain how to get
to the supermarket, how
to use the washing
machine behind the house,
and where to hang
the laundry, just
on the other side of
my father's garden.
Guests are free to pick
lettuce and tomatoes, I add.
There were lots of tomatoes
this year, but most of them
spoiled in the July rain.
I pretend not to watch
them, to be discreet.
I do the housework
and water the garden.
But I can't help noticing how
happy and excited they are.
I hear the girls' voices as
they run across the lawn.
I learn their names.
Since the guests usually
leave the sliding door open,
I overhear what the
parents say to each other
as they settle into the house,
as they unpack their suitcases
and decide what
to have for lunch.
The cottage where
my family lives
is a few yards away,
behind a tall hedge
that forms a kind screen.
For years our house
was just a room
that served as both kitchen and
bedroom for the three of us.
Then, two years ago
when I turned 13,
my mother started working
for the elderly gentleman.
And after saving
up enough money,
my parents asked the man who
owns the property if they
could add a small room for me.
My father is the caretaker.
He looks after the big
house, chops the wood,
works the fields
and the vineyard.
He looks after the horses, which
the owner loves with a passion.
The owner lives abroad, but
he's not a foreigner like us.
He comes every now
and then on his own.
He doesn't have a family.
During the days, he
goes horseback riding.
In the evenings, he reads
in front of the fireplace.
Then he goes away again.
Not many people rent his
house other than in summer.
The winters here are biting, and
in spring there's lots of rain.
In the mornings from
September to June,
my father drives me to school
where I feel out of place.
I don't mix easily with others.
I don't look like anyone else.
The girls in this family
resemble each other.
You can tell right away
that they're sisters.
They've already put on
matching bathing suits
to go to the beach later on.
The beach is about
15 miles from here.
The mother looks
like a girl, too.
She's small and thin.
She wears her long hair loose.
Her shoulders are delicate.
She walks barefoot on the
grass, even though the father
tells her not to, saying--
and he's right-- that
there might be porcupines,
hornets, snakes.
After a few hours, it's as
if they've always lived here.
The things they brought
for a week in the country
are scattered all over the
place, books, magazines,
a laptop computer,
dolls, hoodies,
colored pencils, pads of
paper, flip-flops, sunscreen.
At lunch, I hear
fork striking plates.
I notice each time one of them
sets down a glass on the table.
I detect the calm thread
of their conversation,
the sound and smell
of the coffee pot,
smoke from a cigarette.
After lunch, the father
asks one of the girls
to bring him his glasses.
For a long time he
studies a roadmap.
He list small towns to visit
nearby, archaeological sites,
ruins.
The mother isn't interested.
She says, this is her
only week of the year
without appointments
and obligations.
Later on, the father heads off
to the sea with his daughters.
He asks me as they're leaving
how long it takes to get there.
Which of the beaches is nicest?
He asks me about the weather
forecast for the week,
and I tell him there
is a heat wave coming.
The mother stays home.
She's put on her bathing
suit anyway to get some sun.
She stretches out on one
of the lounge chairs.
I assume she's
going to take a nap.
But when I go to
hang up the wash,
I see her writing something.
She writes by hand in a little
notebook resting on her thighs.
Now and then, she lifts
her head and looks intently
at the landscape
that surrounds us.
She stares at the various
greens of the lawn, the hills,
the woods in the distance,
the glaring blue of the sky,
the yellow hay,
the bleached fence,
and the low stone wall that
marks the property line.
She studies everything
I look at every day.
But I wonder what
else she sees in it.
When the sun starts
to go down, they
put on sweaters and long
pants to shield themselves
from mosquitoes.
The father and the girls have
wet hair from the hot showers
they took after the beach.
The girls tell their
mother about their trip,
the burning sand, the
slightly murky water,
the gentle, disappointing waves.
The whole family goes
for a short walk.
They go to look at the
horses, the donkeys,
a wild boar kept in a
pen behind the stables.
They go to see the
flock of sheep that
passes in front of the house
every day around this time,
blocking for a few minutes
the cars on the dusty road.
The father keeps taking
pictures with his cell phone.
He shows the girls
the small plum trees,
the fig trees, the olives.
He says, fruit picked
straight from the tree
tastes different
because it smells
of the sun, the countryside.
Parents open a bottle
of wine on the patio.
They taste some cheese,
the local honey.
They admire the
blazing landscape
and marvel at the
huge glowing clouds
the color of
pomegranates in October.
Evening falls.
They hear frogs, crickets,
the rustle of the wind.
In spite of the
breeze, they decide
to eat outside to take advantage
of the lingering light.
My father and I eat
inside in silence.
He doesn't look up when he eats.
With my mother away, there is
no conversation during dinner.
She is the one who
talks at meals.
My mother can't
stand this place.
Like my father, she comes
from much farther away
than anyone who vacations here.
She hates living
in this country,
in the middle of nowhere.
She says that the
people here aren't nice,
that they're closed.
I don't miss her complaining.
I don't like listening to her,
even though she's probably
right.
Sometimes when she
complains too much,
my father sleeps in the car
instead of in bed with her.
After dinner, the girls
wander around the lawn
following fireflies.
They play with
their flashlights.
The parents sit on the patio
contemplating the starry sky,
the intense darkness.
The mother sips some
hot water with lemon.
The father, a little grappa.
They say that being here is all
they need, that even the air is
different, that it cleanses.
How lovely, they
say, being together
like this, away from everyone.
First thing in the morning,
I go to the chicken coop
to gather eggs.
They're warm and pale, filthy.
I put a few in a
bowl and bring them
to the guests for breakfast.
Normally, there's no
one around, and I just
leave them on the patio table.
But then I notice
through the sliding door
that the girls
are already awake.
I see bags of cookies
on the sofa, crumbs,
a cereal box overturned
on the coffee table.
The girls are trying to swat
the flies that buzz around
the house in the morning.
The older one is
holding the flyswatter.
The little sister, frustrated,
complains that she's still
waiting for her turn.
She says she wants
to swat them, too.
I put down the eggs and
go back to our house.
Then I knock on their door and
lend the girls our flyswatter.
That way they're both happy.
I don't repeat the fact that
it's better to kill the flies
before you go to bed.
It's clear that
they're having fun,
while the parents, in
spite of the annoying
flies and the girls'
racket, continue sleeping.
After two days, a
predictable routine sets in.
In the late morning, the
father goes to the cafe in town
to buy milk and the paper,
to get a second coffee.
He pops over to the
supermarket if need be.
When he gets back, he
goes running in the hills
despite the humidity.
One time, he comes home
rattled after crossing paths
with a sheepdog that blocked his
way, even though, in the end,
nothing happened.
The mother does what I do.
She sweeps the floor,
cooks, washes dishes.
At least once a day, she
hangs up the laundry.
Our clothes mingle and
dry on a shared line.
She tells her husband,
clasping the laundry basket
in her arms, how
happy this makes her.
Since they live in the city
in a crowded apartment,
she can never hang their clothes
out in the open like this.
After lunch, the father
takes the girls to the beach,
and the mother stays home alone.
She stretches out and
smokes a cigarette,
writing in her notebook with
an air of concentration.
One day back from
the beach, the girls
run around for hours
trying to catch crickets
that jump through the grass.
They snatch them up.
They put a few in a jar with
little pieces of tomato stolen
from their parents' salads.
They turn them into
pets, even naming them.
The next day, the
crickets die, suffocated
in the jar, and the girls cry.
They bury them under
one of the plum trees
and put some wildflowers on top.
Another day, the
father discovers
that one of the flip-flops
he's left outside is missing.
I tell him that a
fox probably took it.
There's been one
prowling around.
I tell my father, who knows
the habits and hideouts of all
the animals around
here, and he manages
to find the shoe,
along with a ball
and a shopping bag abandoned
by the previous family.
I realize how much the guests
like this rural, unchanging
landscape, how much
they appreciate
every detail, how these things
help them think, rest, dream.
When the girls pick
blackberries staining
the pretty dresses
they're wearing,
the mother doesn't
get mad at them.
Instead, she laughs.
She asks the father
to take a picture
and then throws the
dresses in the wash.
At the same time, I wonder what
they know about the loneliness
here.
What do they know about
the days always the same
in our dilapidated cottage?
The nights when the wind
blows so hard the earth
seems to shake, or when the
sound of rain keeps me awake?
The months we live
alone among the hills,
the horses, the
insects, the birds that
pass over the fields?
Would they like the harsh quiet
that rains here all winter?
On the last night,
more cars arrive.
Friends of the parents
have been invited along
with their children, who
run around on the meadow.
A couple of people report
that the traffic was
light coming in from the city.
The adults take a
look around the house
and walk in the garden.
At sunset, the table on
the patio is already set.
I hear everything as they eat.
The laughter and chatter
are louder tonight.
The family relates
all their mishaps
in the country, the
tomato eating crickets,
the funeral under the plum
tree, the sheepdog, the fox that
carried off the flip-flop.
The mother says that being in
touch with nature like this
has been good for the girls.
At a certain point, a cake
comes out with candles,
and I realize it's
the father's birthday.
He's turning 45.
Everyone sings, and
they slice the cake.
My father and I finish
up some overripe grapes.
I'm about to clear
the table when
I hear a knock at the door.
I see the girls,
hesitant, out of breath.
They give me a plate with
two slices of cake on it,
one for me and
one for my father.
They dash off before
I can say thanks.
We eat the cake while the guests
talk about politics, trips,
life in the city.
Someone asks the mother
where she got the cake.
It came from a bakery
in their neighborhood,
she says, adding that one of
the other guests brought it up.
She mentions the
name of the bakery,
the piazza where it's situated.
My father lays down his
fork and lowers his head.
His eyes are agitated
when he looks at me.
He gets up abruptly
and then steps out
to smoke a cigarette unobserved.
We used to live
in the city, too.
My father sold flowers
in that very piazza.
My mother used to help.
They spent their days
next to each other
in a small but pleasant
stand, arranging bouquets
that people took home
to decorate their tables
and terraces.
New to this country,
they learned
the names of the flowers.
Rose, sunflower,
carnation, daisy.
They kept them, there stems
submerged in rows of buckets.
One night, three men showed up.
My father was alone.
My mother, pregnant
with me at the time,
was at home because he didn't
want her to work at night.
It was late.
The other stores around
the piazza were closed,
and my father was about
to lower his grate.
One of the men asked
him to open up again,
saying that he was about to
go and see his girlfriend.
He wanted a nice bouquet.
My father agreed that
he'd make him one,
even though the men were
rude, a little drunk.
When my father held
up the bouquet,
the man said that it
was skimpy and asked
him to make it bigger.
My father added more flowers,
an excessive number of them,
until the man was satisfied.
He wrapped paper
around the bouquet,
then he bound it up with
colored ribbon, tying a bow.
He told him the price.
The man pulled some
money out of his wallet.
It wasn't enough.
And when my father refused
to hand over the bouquet,
the man told him that he was
an idiot, that he didn't even
know how to put together a nice
bouquet for a beautiful girl.
Then together with the other,
he started beating my father
until his mouth
filled with blood,
until his front
teeth were shattered.
My father yelled, but at
that hour no one heard.
They said, go back to
wherever you came from.
They took the bouquet and left
him like that on the ground.
My father went to
the emergency room.
He couldn't eat solid
foods for a year.
After I was born, when he
saw me for the first time,
he couldn't say a word.
Ever since, he's
struggled to speak.
He garbles his words as
if he were an old man.
He's ashamed to smile
because of his missing teeth.
My mother and I understand
him, but others don't.
They think since he is
a foreigner, that he
doesn't speak the language.
Sometimes they even
think he's mute.
When the pears and red apples
that grow in the garden
are ripe, we cut them into thin
slices, almost transparent,
so he can savor them.
One of his compatriots
told him about this job
in this secluded place.
He wasn't familiar
with the countryside.
He'd always lived in cities.
He can live and work here
without opening his mouth.
He's not afraid
of being attacked.
He prefers to live among the
animals, cultivating the land.
He's become used to this
untamed place that protects him.
When he talks to me as
he drives me to school,
he always says the same
thing, that he couldn't
make anything of his life.
All he wants me to do is
study and finish school,
go to college, and then
go far away from them.
The next day, late
in the morning,
the father starts
to load the car.
I see four people, tanned,
even more closely knit.
They don't want to leave.
At breakfast, they
say that they'd
like to come back next year.
Nearly all the guests say
the same thing when they go.
A few faithfully return.
But for most of
them, once is enough.
Before heading out,
the mother shows
me the stuff in the
fridge that they don't
want to take back to the city.
She tells me that she has
grown quite fond of this house,
that she already misses it.
Maybe when she's
feeling stressed
or overwhelmed by work,
she'll think of this place.
The clean air, the hills,
the clouds blazing at sunset.
I wish the family safe
travels and say goodbye.
I stand there waiting until
the car's out of sight.
Then I start to prepare the
house for the new family that's
supposed to get here tomorrow.
I make the beds.
I tidy the room the
girls turned upside down.
I sweep the flies they swatted.
They've forgotten--
or left on purpose--
a few things they don't
need, things I hold onto.
Pictures the girls grew,
shells they picked up
at the beach, the last drops
of a perfumed shower gel,
shopping lists in the
faint, small script
that the mother used on
other sheets of paper
to write all about us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Jhumpa, thank you so much
for that beautiful story.
I think it touches on
so many of the topics
that this conference
is about and that we
talked about in some
of the earlier panels.
But first, I want to ask
you just some questions
about this story.
Can you tell us how you
came to write this story,
if there was something that
sort of sparked it in your mind,
or how you came to write it?
- I came to write it because
I was living in Rome.
And one of the lovely
things about my life in Rome
is that every day I end up
speaking inevitably all three
of the languages that I speak.
I speak Italian when
I go out of the house.
I speak English inside
the house with my family.
And I speak Bengali
with many, many people
from Bangladesh
who live in Rome,
who work all over the
place in Trastevere, which
is the neighborhood we live in.
They sell things in makeshift
stalls on the streets.
Everything from
shoes and suitcases,
to bed sheets and tablecloths.
They work in the markets.
They peel the vegetables.
The butcher shops.
In any case, they form part of--
the Bangladeshi community
forms part of my day
to day life in almost every
establishment that I frequent.
And I talk to them.
I ask them what they
like, what they don't
like about living in Rome.
And from the very
beginning, I heard
a lot of troubling
impressions, anecdotes.
And this grew out of--
I mean, that moment at the end
of the story, that violent act,
is based on something I
heard one man tell me about.
He actually worked
in the flower shop
I used to go to all the
time to buy flowers.
This had happened to him
in another neighborhood,
not in our neighborhood.
And it was something I heard
quite early on in my life
there, and it stayed with me.
And then some years
later, I was on vacation
with my family in a
place called Capalbio,
which is about two hours
north of Rome, right
over the border in Tuscany.
But not the sort of
Tuscany people think of,
most people think of.
A more kind of Cape Cod-like
Tuscany, if you will.
And we were there.
And we were renting
a friend's house.
And I was very aware of
the caretaker's daughter,
who was a young girl, very
small child at the time.
She was very curious
about my kids
and would pop out sometimes
from their little house,
venture out to say hello.
And I spent most of the
vacation thinking about her
and wondering what her life
would be like in 10 years.
So the story was
inspired by that.
- You mentioned that
one of the stories
that worked its way into this
piece you heard some years ago.
Of course, stories like
that, unfortunately,
have happened all over
the place and have
happened for a long time.
And I think we're
starting to hear
more with more stories of
violence against immigrants,
at least here in the US.
Especially now, but
elsewhere as well as right
wing parties have started
to assert themselves
all over the place.
When I told people
that I was going
to get to speak with
you today, and I said,
she's going to be reading
this story that was in The New
Yorker, many people
got very excited
because they had read the story.
And in talking with friends
and other writers, many of them
assume that the story
took place in Italy.
Because it mentions that it's
translated from the Italian,
because you're known
to live in Italy.
But in the story
itself, the location
is sort of deliberately
unspecified,
as is the home nation of
the narrator and her family.
And the truth is that it could
almost take place anywhere,
including even in the US.
And I'm curious
about your decision
to not name the two central
locations in the story, where
it takes place and then where
the family itself is from.
It's such an interesting choice.
- Well, yeah, it is a choice.
And it's something I've
been choosing to do or not
do for some years now.
I think all of my
Italian writing
has been taking place in an
invented space, if you will.
It was interesting because I
asked my son, who's almost 16,
if he wanted to read the story.
Because he was sort of vaguely
aware that it had come out.
I think he saw it, or heard
me and my husband talking
about it, or something.
So I said, well, you know,
if you want, you can read it.
It's pretty short.
[LAUGHTER]
And he said, sure, OK.
And he read it.
And I said, could you
recognize where it took place?
And he said,
Wellfleet, Cape Cod,
where they actually-- my kids
and my husband are right now.
And I'm going to
join them tomorrow.
And it is a place--
we used to go there
much more often.
It's a place we love
very much and a place
in which we feel a little bit
like the family in that story.
And we have that kind of
relationship with the place.
I think the story is very
much about how people--
how a single place can be
read in so many different ways
and experienced in different
ways, depending on who you are
and the things we project on to
places that aren't necessarily
ours.
But the reason I don't want
to name the place, to specify
the place-- even
though, yes, it was
inspired by this small
town called Capalbio,
which is in Italy, which is in
this part of the planet Earth.
And there are some--
some Italian friends
read it and say, ah, Capalbio.
And they know right away.
And others aren't so sure.
But I really feel very
strongly right now
about leaving the specificity--
just to leave it
entirely open in terms
of where the story is placed.
And I think this is
probably my own desire
to liberate myself from a
certain weight I feel in terms
of being connected to specific
geographical and cultural
points of reference.
- And I think in doing
that also, like you said,
it sort of allows other people
to overlay their own sort
of experience in it.
Like your son seeing
Wellfleet in there,
which is a place that I
happen to know as well.
And for other
people, too, I think
to sort of make their own
meaning out of the story.
This is sort of the larger
questions of the conference.
In an interview with The
New Yorker about this story,
you mentioned that you do think
of this as a political story.
And I think they had
asked you, do you
see this as a
political story or do
you see it as something else?
And you had a wonderful quote.
You said, all my work is about
identity, about belonging.
And therefore, all of my
work may be read politically.
And I love what you said about
that idea of the point of view
shift, where--
I think a lot of
times people will say
that something is political.
And I'm curious about what
your thoughts are about what
political writing is.
Do you think that there
is such a thing as writing
that isn't political?
So there's a big question.
- That is a big question.
I mean, I think
certainly most of my work
can be looked at through that.
I mean, I'm not writing it with
any specific intent, message,
anything like that.
But I think it would be naive
to not think of that reality.
I remember when I was
growing up, my father--
so my family and I moved
to Cambridge in 1969.
And he would say now
and then, well, it's
thanks to President
Nixon that we're here.
And I remember
growing up thinking,
why is my dad saying that?
Why is this even relevant?
And Nixon's bad.
Why do we have to
talk about this?
But then I realized
what he was getting at,
that it's all about laws, it's
all about immigration laws.
And it's all about these
political realities.
It's about governments
making decisions
about how to negotiate
their borders.
And so, yes, as a result of
that law, and that moment,
and those policies, in
that time, in that year,
my father got the
clearance to come
with his wife and his
daughter to the United States.
And there they remained.
But I think for
someone who is actually
doing the border crossing,
you never lose sight of that
no matter who's in
charge at the moment,
even if it's Richard Nixon.
You sort of have that sense of--
that weird sense of gratitude
that the doors opened for you.
And it is political.
- Yeah, I think it's--
what you're saying reminds
me that it's very difficult
to separate the context in which
your work is being inspired
or is taking place from
what the work itself is.
And I don't know that that's
even necessarily a thing
that we want to do.
One of the things that
I find myself struggling
with as a writer is, as
you say, when people view
your work through this political
lens, of trying to figure out
what I as a fiction writer--
I spend my day making
up stories about people.
So as a friend of mine
said, I'm spending my day
with imaginary people
in imaginary places
doing imaginary stuff.
But at the same time, I hope
that the work that I'm creating
and that you're creating speaks
to the world that we're in.
And being in that
strange border area
has been a thing
that I'm learning
to negotiate as a writer
sort of starting out in this.
And curious about what you
think the role of the writer
is in the current
sociopolitical climate?
Do we have a responsibility to
directly and consciously try
and talk about those issues
in our work or off the page?
Or is that really just
part of the meaning
that critics and readers
should be bringing to our work?
Is it sort of above our
pay grade, so to speak?
- I write to feel free.
So I don't write
for any purpose,
to answer to anything other
than a desire on my part.
It's a very selfish occupation.
I will not lie about it.
If I'm talking to
anybody, it's usually
to a group of dead
writers who have guided me
and taught me how to live.
I feel that that is
where my energy lies.
You produce the work.
It's born.
And it has its own life.
And it's received.
And there's really very
little you can do about it.
It's either read,
or it's ignored.
It's understood.
It's misunderstood.
It's maligned.
It's praised.
It's read in all sorts of ways.
- And probably will be read
in all sorts of different ways
10 years from now,
50 years from now.
- Of course.
So I mean, I think
it's foolish to try
to write to solve anything,
to explain anything.
I think writing can, and
does, communicate great truths
to people who read, and read
carefully, and are searching
as readers.
And that is why
literature speaks to me.
But it's a very
personal relationship.
And my relationship
to the writers I read
is unlike that relationship
between another person
and those same writers.
And everyone-- we all have
our different constellations.
So that's where I
am as an artist.
And then there's
another conversation
that happens that I'm not--
that I don't
participate in, and I
have no interest in overseeing.
- In some ways, I think one
of the paradoxes of being
a writer, and especially
a fiction writer,
is that I think when I come
to the page, I am not--
as you say, I'm not coming in
with an agenda or message that
I want to write about.
I'm not thinking, now I'm going
to write a book that is going
to teach people about this.
I'm writing in some way because
there's something in the story
or in the characters
that's intrigued me.
But then when those
stories-- as you said,
they go out into the world,
and they get interpreted,
misinterpreted,
translated in some way--
we heard in some of
the morning panels,
for any of you who were here--
we heard a little bit about
the power of narrative
and the power of story.
And it's something that I
wanted to sort of bring up
for our discussion.
Sarah Leah Whitson was talking.
She showed some videos which
they were using in the Middle
East to try and
work in Saudi Arabia
to end the guardianship
system, in which men
are assigned to be the guardians
of women in their lives.
And she talked about working
with women in Saudi Arabia
to kind of figure out, what
is the narrative of the story?
What is the story that we
want to show in the video that
will resonate with
the women that we're
trying to talk to and
even the men that we're
trying to talk to.
And Kari Hong told us a little
story at the end of her talk
in which she mentioned
that her father said,
we're lucky to live in a country
that we're allowed to disagree
with the government.
Because he knew what it had
been like to live in a regime
that didn't allow
that kind of freedom.
And this is not actually
a question, I guess.
But I'm interested in
talking about that position
that writers find
themselves in where
we create these sort of texts.
And these narratives
do have a lot of power
to go out beyond us.
And yet, those aren't-- that's
not something we can control.
And I'm not even
sure it is something
that we should control.
- Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I think that's--
yes, I think you're
rightly embellishing
what I was trying to put forth
when I was talking earlier,
just this idea that there
are different spheres, right?
Different spheres of activity.
And there's the writing.
There's the reading.
There's the perception.
There's the life of
the book over time.
There's the relationship
of the book with the world.
The world is
constantly shifting.
The situation is
So the book has greater or
lesser resonance depending on--
- Or just different
resonance, yeah.
- Depending on who's reading
it, when they're reading it,
how they're reading it.
I mean, just from a purely
personal point of view,
Anna Karenina meant
one thing to me
when I read it
presumptuously at 16.
It meant something
very different
when I read it when
I was breastfeeding
my newborn daughter.
And it will mean
something very different
the next time I sit
down to read it.
Because I'm not
that same person.
It remains a point of
reference, but you see it
in a totally different way.
And it speaks-- it's telling
you completely different things.
- And of course, yeah, I've
had a similar experience
with The Count of Monte Cristo
as a favorite book of mine.
And of course, the
text remains the same.
And so when I read it--
my sister was in college.
And she gave it to me.
And I was an adolescent,
and I was really taken
with the adventure story at 12.
And then I read it again
at 15, and I was very taken
with the romance in the book.
And I thought it
was very romantic.
And then I got older,
and I started to see it
as this sort of morality story.
And now I read it
as this question of,
how much are you really
allowed to play god?
How much can you do that?
And all of those
things-- obviously,
those changes have happened
in me, as you're saying.
It has this different resonance
depending on the context
in which you read it.
I think that one
thing that writers--
we writers can and do
have to really consider
sort of which stories we tell.
And in the story that
you read, "The Boundary,"
the mother who comes on vacation
is also a writer of some kind.
We don't know exactly
what she's doing when
she's writing in her notebook.
But we have the sense
that she is maybe
going to tell her
version of this trip
and her version of the story
of the narrator and her father.
But of course, she
doesn't know the things
that the narrator knows and the
things that the narrator tells
us about what happened
to the father.
And if this mother
tells the story,
she's almost certainly
going to leave out
some really important context
to the story at the very least.
And it, for me,
raised the questions
of who should tell the story?
Who's allowed to
tell the stories?
And thinking about
some of the panels
from this morning where
questions were raised about,
well, if we are
coming from the West,
and we are talking to
other parts of the world,
is this sort of a narrative
that we're imposing on them?
Or to what degree do we allow
them to tell their own stories?
And it's something
that I find myself
wrestling with in my writing.
What stories am I
allowed to tell?
What stories am I going
to be good at telling?
I'm curious what you
think about all of that.
- Well, I think
the writer should
have no identity whatsoever.
- Do you think that's possible?
- I'm trying.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm trying to get to that point.
But I think I've
always been that way.
I think I've never
had an identity.
I've never understood
what identity was.
And whenever I started to
understand what it was,
it terrified me.
And every time my life
seems to take some sort of--
something more than
a penciled-in shape,
I run away from it.
But I think this is crucial for
the artist, for the writer--
especially the writer--
to always evade any kind
of precise identity.
Because it is that vacillating,
formless state in which you
can shape-shift into anything or
anyone at any time in any place
that allows you to create,
and to create characters,
and to create a world that isn't
yours, and to think your way,
feel your way,
understand your way
into other hearts, other souls.
And so that's how I felt as--
as a young girl, I felt that.
And I think because I
wasn't a writer then,
because I was just a child,
it was a little bit scary.
Because I think
in some sense, we
want identity because
identity is like a home.
It's like shelter.
It provides walls, and
a roof, and a sense--
a semblance of security,
which is what home
is, a semblance of security.
But I think that as I--
once I became a writer, that
state, that state of being,
that stateless state
of being, if you will,
became my instrument.
It's my only instrument.
And I think that is something
that I very carefully cultivate
at this point.
Because I know that that
is the only instrument
that allows me to work.
- It's interesting
that you phrase it
as having no identity versus
having multiple identities.
I'm trying to think about
whether those two things are
flip sides of the same
coin, or if there's
a difference between
feeling that you are not
rooted anywhere or feeling
that you have multiple roots.
I'm thinking of the
conversation we had at lunch
where you mentioned
you feel like you've
got a life in Italy, and
you've got a life here,
and you've got many different
lives in different places.
- I have many lives,
but I don't have--
identity is a different thing.
Identity is a different thing
that you feel or you don't.
Right?
So my mother feels
Indian, right?
Even right at this moment
in her home in Rhode Island.
She feels Indian.
And nothing will make
her not feel that.
That's identity.
I don't have that.
I don't feel Indian.
I don't feel American.
I don't feel Italian.
I don't feel English.
I was just in London,
and people say, well, you
must feel a little bit English.
You were born in London.
How can I feel English?
I mean, what does that mean?
I mean, maybe it's
just my own inability
to connect to identity.
But I think I've--
because of the way I was
raised and the world in which I
was raised, and the worlds
in which I was raised,
I was always suspicious of it.
I was always
suspicious of identity.
And now in my adult
life, again, I
feel like I have
to remain vigilant.
But maybe it's just a
self-protective mechanism.
Because I can say this.
I can sit up here and say, well,
I don't believe in identity.
But I think I also feel I've
suffered so much in my life
for lacking an identity.
And it has been a source
of anguish for me to lack,
to be able to-- to not be able
to say, I'm this, or I'm that.
And it's that absence,
that absence of identity
that I talk about a
little bit in my last book
and in other words where
I talk about language.
It's that vacuum,
that black space,
that silence that was
a terrifying reality.
So I think what I've constructed
around that is my own--
I'm sure it's my own defense
mechanism as well as something
I try to embrace as the
key for my creativity.
It's both things.
- It's so fascinating.
I feel like I could talk to
you about this for another half
an hour.
But I think we're meant to move
on to the audience questions.
So are there question cards?
Thank you.
All right, this is
where I'm going to try
to read your handwriting.
All right, so this is
a question about the--
you mentioned that the title
of your story in English,
it's "The Boundary," but
in Italian, it's [ITALIAN]..
- [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
- And it says, it suggests--
it's not only boundary, but
it also suggests confinement.
And this question is, can
you discuss the many senses
of confinement in our cultures
in terms of who's confined
and who gets to do that,
and in what way that
maybe relates to the story?
- Well, boundaries are created
to keep people confined
in some sense, to demarcate.
And so much of
human civilization
has been about this reality,
negotiating this reality,
fighting over this issue,
these lines we draw.
But I mean, I think
it's a rich metaphor.
I don't know.
I mean, I haven't really
thought about it that much.
But I suppose, as you
say, as you mentioned,
the mother character
is the writer.
And she's sort of me.
I was that mother in some sense.
And I was also the
little girl, of course.
I'm everybody in the story.
But I think, of
course, each of us
is confined in our own reality.
I think that's the point.
And the writer writes to
get out of one's reality.
At least that's why
I started writing,
was to get out of my
skin and my reality.
Partly because I was curious.
Partly because I didn't
really like my reality.
Partly because it just felt
exciting and different.
But I think in the end, we each
have our reality, our thoughts,
our perceptions, our minds.
And this is the boundary.
We are individual boundaries
of incredibly complex, unique,
individual boundaries.
And so much of life,
and literature,
and our problems, our woes,
are about the inability
to communicate
openly and clearly,
the inability to negotiate
those boundaries.
And I think my work has
really been about that
from the very beginning,
looking at it in all sorts
of variations on the theme.
- And that touches on one
of the next questions.
It says, could you
say more about what
you mean by saying that
you write to be free?
And I think this
is related to what
you've just been talking about.
This person asks, what
does that mean to you
in terms of being
free in your writing?
Is it just, as
you said, the ways
that you can communicate with
each other sort of clearly?
Or is it also
about, in some ways,
being able to step
outside of your own life,
your own experience?
What does that mean
to you when you say
that you're writing to be free?
- It means I'm
writing to feel free.
It means that--
- Sorry, whoever
asked the question.
[LAUGHTER]
- I mean-- no, I
don't mean to be--
I don't mean to
dismiss the question.
It's a very complex question.
And I'm trying to
write myself an answer.
I think one is in flight or not.
But I think I am someone who
has been wary of expectations
handed to me.
And wanting to-- objecting
to certain expectations.
- You mean expectations
of what people
expected you would write about?
Or what you would
say about them?
- Who I would be.
I mean, forget about writing.
Just as a human being.
Expectations on me for who
I would be, how I would be,
how I would live my life,
how I should live my life.
What I would do with my life.
I felt this keenly
from a very young age.
And I think part
of it was because I
was raised by displaced
people who had
a very keen sense of identity.
And so that creates a
very charged environment
in the family--
at least in my family--
in terms of how I
was expected to be,
and what I was
expected to be, and who
I was expected to be all of
those things with, and et
cetera, et cetera.
So I felt incredibly under
intense forms of control.
Not just-- I'm not--
this is not to say,
oh, my parents wanted
all of these things.
It was more than my
mother and father.
It was a sort of community.
It was a world within a world.
It was layers of expectations.
It was expectations when I would
go to Calcutta with my parents.
It was expectations when
I was in this country.
It was expectations of
people outside of my family.
And ultimately they
were the expectations
that I was bringing to the
equation, the worst of them
all.
Because I wanted to somehow
please absolutely everybody.
- In all of those disparate--
- In all of the disparate
worlds and ways.
And it really is a recipe
for intense unhappiness
and disaster.
- Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
- So I tried to find
a way out of that.
And that's the freedom I seek.
I seek the freedom from that
weight and that obligation.
The freedom to be.
The freedom to be happy and--
which is lightly said
but painfully gained.
- This is a slightly
lighter question.
Someone would like to know
who are the dead writers
that you speak to--
[LAUGHTER]
--when you have
that conversation
with the dead
writers you mention?
- Well, it depends
on the graves I'm
going to visit on
any particular day.
I was reading Kafka
on the plane today.
But in general, for
the past several years
I've predominantly been
reading Italian writers.
Most of them dead.
Not all.
And I've been translating
a living author, perhaps
Italy's finest living
author, Domenico Starnone.
But really, I mean, the
constellations are vast,
as they are in real
life in the real sky.
So there just-- I mean, I'm old
enough to be able to say, well,
those were the writers--
I mean, I can sort of link
every book to a different group
of writers, shall I say.
But this story, for
example, I don't
know what it comes out of.
But certainly, I think
probably the writer
Agota Kristof inspired this
story, a Hungarian author who
moves to Switzerland and--
flees to Switzerland
with her family,
and learns French,
and writes in French.
Wrote in French.
She's no longer living.
And it was reading her, a
great discovery when I was
beginning my Italian journey.
A great point of reference
for me to read her
and to think about what
she did and her example.
So this story was
inspired by her.
- When you think of yourself
as talking to those writers,
do you talk to
them in your head?
Or do you see your
work as, in some ways,
being your
conversation with them?
- I don't know if it's
anything as conscious as that.
I mean, I think reading for
me is just a form of writing.
No, that came out wrong.
I think writing is
a form of reading.
I think writing is a
form of reading for me.
When I was young, when
I was a little girl,
I learned how to read
around six or seven.
And I couldn't read
without copying
what I was reading
in some strange form
almost simultaneously.
I don't know why I did that.
But that's what I did.
And that's how I
started writing.
So that's remained a constant,
in that if I read something
deeply enough--
which is how we read when we're
just learning how to read,
right?
Because we don't know how to--
we're not used to it yet.
And it's such a revolution.
It must be.
I mean, it is.
It's such a revolution to be
able to learn how to read.
My god, it's, like,
the best thing ever.
- It's such a--
my son is seven.
And he taught himself
to read quite early.
But it was this
revelation to him,
like you said, that there was--
somebody somewhere else at
some other point in time
had written down these
words and had this idea.
And that now this
idea was in his head
was this sort of
mind-blowing idea to him.
That in some ways,
he could have their--
he could get some
semblance of their ideas.
Like you said, it's such
a transformative thing.
- Yeah, I mean, I think, for me,
the transformative experience
was more just the pure solace,
the first solace of life
is reading.
And then I start to
echo what I'm reading.
And so even now I feel that
that's what I'm doing somehow.
I mean, in a less
mechanical way.
Because when I was
young, I would read.
And I would I would
read something.
I would read Little
House On the Prairie,
then I would write this weird
version of the same story,
right?
[LAUGHTER]
- I did that also, actually.
My mother recently
found sketchbooks
in which I had drawn and
illustrated little stories.
There's little Mary.
And there's little Laura.
- Wagons, right.
- There's a lawn, blue and pink.
And yeah.
- But I think as
one grows older--
and I mean, if you
end up being a writer,
then that back and forth becomes
much more complex and layered.
And then there are
influences that you're--
either you're consciously
channeling them,
or you're unconsciously
channeling them.
You pick things up.
You're not aware.
You're not aware of all
of the particles that
are moving around in the
room in any given moment.
- Are there contemporary or--
not undead.
Non-dead, alive writers
that you have been reading
over the past few years?
- Well, as I said, Domenico
Starnone, whose two novels
I've recently translated.
One is called Trick in Italian--
in English, sorry.
And the other is Ties.
I recently very much
admired the novel
by Neel Mukherjee, my
friend, who's here with me
today, A State of Freedom.
We had a wonderful
conversation about that novel
not long ago in Princeton.
But in general, I don't read
very much contemporary fiction.
And at this point, I don't
really read fiction in English
either.
So it's a lot of 19th
century and 20th century
Italian authors at the
moment who are feeding me.
- Along those lines, we
have a couple questions
about translation.
Someone says, can
you talk a little bit
about your experience of
translating the story that you
read and your book.
In other words, you wrote
in Italian and then someone
else translated it.
And this story you wrote and
then translated yourself.
And following on
that, someone wants
to know, so when you translate
from Italian to English,
did you edit substantially?
Did you change it substantially?
What was that
process like for you?
- To translate this story?
It was really weird.
It's a very weird thing to
try to translate myself.
It's very disorienting.
I mean, it's a level of
disorientation that is--
it's like the final
frontier, in a way.
The other day with my
family we walked out
on the breakwater
at Provincetown,
that final little bit that
I wrote about many years ago
in The Namesake, the
novel I'm convinced
I presented in this room.
In any case.
And as I was walking this time
with my family, my kids now
racing ahead of their
old parents, my son
coming back saying, can
you speed it up, guys?
We've reached the end.
Anyway.
But I was going slowly, partly
because I was reflecting on--
I mean, it was in
Provincetown 20 years ago
that I really felt
born as a writer,
fully born in a kind of
definitive way, in a way
that I never
subsequently questioned.
Because until that experience--
I was 30 years old.
And everything, all of the
sort of writing activity
before then, it
was all in pencil.
I was ready to erase everything.
Not literally the words, so
much as just the presumption.
And after those seven
months in Provincetown,
something happened.
And I felt that it was
ink and not pencil, that I
was ink and no longer a pencil.
In any case, I was walking
out across the breakwater.
And I was thinking,
well, 20 years ago,
I started writing
seriously in English.
And then 15 years after
that, I moved to Italy.
And I started writing
in a new language.
And then a couple
of years ago, I
started translating
out of Italian the work
of somebody else into English.
And now I'm writing in
Italian and translating myself
out of Italian.
And I thought, I think that
is that final lighthouse
that you get to.
And then you just
can't go anywhere else.
I think I've gotten
to that point.
So translating myself is that.
It is quite-- it is arduous
and bewildering for me.
I've just finished a
short novel in Italian
that I'm thinking
of translating.
And I mean, I'm
sort of dreading it.
Because it's going
to be very hard.
- Do you prefer, though,
to translate it yourself
rather than to turn it
over to someone else?
- I feel completely sort
of torn up about it.
Because on the one
hand, I don't want
anybody else to translate it.
And on the other
hand, I don't really
want to translate it either.
[LAUGHTER]
But I have to.
I have to figure out something.
I think maybe once
I get into it,
into the room with the Italian
version, maybe it will be OK.
I mean, this story was
sort of an experiment.
One day I was
swimming in the pool,
and I thought, well,
it's only 10 pages.
How hard can it be?
And it was hard.
It was hard.
But I think what made it easier
was that I had a lot of time.
It was something I wrote so long
ago now that it's almost like--
I mean, once I write something--
after I write something,
and if enough time goes by,
I completely forget about it.
And it just-- it could
be written by anybody.
- I imagine that would make it
a little bit easier in some ways
to translate it.
Because there's some space.
- Yeah, so once it sort
of hardens like that,
and I don't really connect--
I'm not connected to it
anymore, it might be easier.
I mean, the problem
with this novel
is that I just finished it up.
And it's still-- the spirit of
it is still kind of hovering.
And I don't know if
it's the right time
to immediately translate
it back into English.
But then I feel this horrible
expectation and people
saying, well, when is it
going to be translated?
Because of course,
nobody can read it
if I don't translate it.
I mean, nobody
other than Italians.
And it's very interesting to
be performing this experiment
and to be really living the
reality of how colossally
dominant the English
language is in our world,
and to just realize it, and
to experience it as a writer,
to experience what it means
to write a story in Italian,
in Granta Italia, which is no
longer even in publication,
and to know that
10 people read it.
And that's only because I told
10 people in Rome, guess what?
I have this story.
And I made photocopies
and shared it with them.
The way I used to--
when I used to live in
Boston all those years ago,
and my very first short
story was published
in the Harvard Review.
And I was so ecstatic.
And three people read it.
And three more people read
it because I made photocopies
and gave them to them.
I'm back in that place
as a writer in Italian.
And then it comes out
in The New Yorker,
and it has a totally different
life, a totally different set
of muscles and capacity to--
there's no basis of comparison.
It's absurd.
It's staggering.
It's mind-boggling.
- But it does sound like
it's important to you,
too, that this story does reach
this larger audience, that it--
- You know, I translated this
story totally sort of randomly.
Literally, I was swimming in
the pool one day in Princeton,
thinking, let me just
see what it's like.
I wasn't really thinking about
publishing the story in English
in that sense.
I mean, it just
seemed like a story
I wrote, a kind of
discrete piece of work.
And I'd forgotten about it.
And then I thought, oh,
let me see what happens.
And then my agent said,
what's going on back there?
And I said, well, I
have this little thing.
I don't know.
And The New Yorker
kindly published it.
But I wasn't thinking
about it in that way.
I mean, I think that's
another thing I'm
trying to liberate myself from.
I mean, maybe I'm just
completely crazy at this point.
But just the whole machinery
of publishing, editing.
I don't know.
I'm questioning everything.
- Well, and then I think
all of those mechanisms
are very separate from
the act of creation
and the artistic side of it.
This may be a difficult
question for you to answer.
But you might be one of the
few people who can answer it.
Because you can read in
Italian and in English.
I'm curious if the
responses were different,
if the story was
read differently
in Italy than it has been read
over here in The New Yorker.
Not just in terms of numbers,
but in terms of meaning,
or import, or the meanings that
people are putting onto it.
- I don't know.
I mean, I think the story is--
as you say, I mean, it
could take place anywhere.
And it talks about a very,
unfortunately, rather
widespread problem,
phenomenon in our world
regarding intolerance, and
migration, and attitudes
toward people who are different,
and feeling out of place,
and belonging or not belonging.
And I mean, I think
immigration is one thing
in the Italian context.
And it's a different thing
in the context of the United
States or in the
UK, for example.
They're different places
with different histories,
different reality, so forth.
I mean, I think for the--
I think I am read differently
by Italians in Italian.
And I'm read differently-- as
opposed to people who know me,
the Jhumpa Lahiri
who wrote in English
and was born as an
English language writer.
I think for some
of those readers,
this story comes as a bit
of a, what happened to her?
So some people have said,
well, but your other stories
were like this.
And they were talking about
those kinds of things.
And they sounded more like that.
- Which goes back
to that question
of expectations of what
people expect you to be.
- So in English, there's
a little bit more
of the before and after
comparison conversation more.
Whereas I think in
the Italian context,
Italians are more just sort
of benevolently curious
about what I'm doing.
And they're equally incredulous,
but in a more benevolent way.
Whereas I think in
the American context,
I'm now in a phase where I'm
aware that what I'm doing
is odd and not the expected.
And I have to tolerate much
more of a sort of mixed reviews,
as it were.
I don't read my reviews.
But a mixed sense of people
who just don't like this.
People don't like
what I'm doing.
People are very intolerant.
People just want me to
go back to the old thing
and the old ways.
Don't like this experimentation.
They say things to
my face about it.
And it's interesting,
because I think
it's all part of this quest
to evade the idea of identity,
even a writerly identity,
which can be quite problematic.
Which I think is problematic.
Again, I think the artist has
to shun identity at all costs.
- Well, it's fascinating
to read this story
and see your new direction.
Thank you so much, Jhumpa.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]